stop reality stone
now
I told you I sold it I imagine it's like
breathing free
like suicide so you do understand
not even you would surrender something
so precious I didn't know what it was
then you are the fool that I took you
for and sell Last Chance Charlotte
where's the stone today he pays for the
deaths of my wife and daughter
and get your defenses and get this
manner she
hey everybody as promised this is gonna
be a video for everybody's new weapons
and toys during infinity war now we like
call them toys but Marvel puts new stuff
new suits of armor and movies so that it
can sell new toys
the trade-off being that you know that
they're trying to bait you to buy their
stuff but it looks pretty cool so even
though there are a billion characters or
infinity war mostly the main characters
are getting upgrades and Marvel has
confirmed most of it but there's been
some rumors about the Thanos character
and a couple of the others so I'll try
to explain what's rumor and what's
actually been confirmed and a lot of you
are asking about Super Bowl trailers
because Black Panther is right around
the corner infinity Wars coming up and
Marvel always drops a trailer or Disney
always drops a Marvel trailer during the
Superbowl like last year they did
guardians of the galaxy they did Captain
America Civil War the year before that
so naturally Marvel will be dropping
trailers but here's the really important
thing remember there's gonna be a lot of
comic book trailers because of all the
movies coming this year like Deadpool
venom all the stuff later this year -
that will be dropping in the next two
weeks so not all of it will drop during
the Superbowl this weekend but fun with
weapons starting with Captain America's
shield this is probably the biggest
thing people were talking about this
week because we knew he was getting a
new shield black panther literally says
get this man a new shield then they cut
to a picture of Captain America during
the infinity war trailer and if you
couldn't tell this is made to look like
the classic version of the shield before
he got the vibranium on remember when he
was wearing that cloth suit the very
first version of the costume he
complained about that recently I'll play
that clip in a second because it's
pretty funny but when you see him
running into battle here you just see
him with the Panther gauntlets on so
what I think is happening is is because
we know how black panthers vibranium
suit works now like it literally just
forms out of some of this bling that's
probably how his shield forms but once
it's fully deployed this is what it
looks like so obviously it's not colored
to look like the classic Captain America
colors but again he's the Nomad
character so he's not using that name
he's not disposing those colors at the
moment I think that'll change through
the course of the film but I think
what's going on during the trailer is is
they just did not finish some of the CG
before they posted the trailer so
there's like a bunch of other stuff
going on in these scenes that they're
going to add later they did that with
the Black Panther movie - they did it
with all the thor ragnarok
trailers but when he's hitting this
outrider he's probably hitting it with
his shield and we just can't see it
because they haven't added the CG for
that yet but the Thanos weapon that
everyone's been talking about is what
they're calling the infinity sword now
there is no infinity sword from the
comic book which is why I'm kind of
suspect about this because they do make
toys for movies based on things that
don't actually appear in the movie best
example of that was the Spider mobile
that they sold for spider-man homecoming
despite the fact that there was no
spider mobile in that movie in the Audi
that he stole from flash totally does
not count
but obviously speaking of the iron
spider costume it probably has the arms
that's unconfirmed still at the rumor
stage but you see the toy so it's like
well you know what it's probably gonna
happen they probably just omitted the
CGI from this scene here I've talked
about it before like there's too much
dead space in this frame here for one of
these movies typically that gets filled
with something that they add with CG
later it's probably the arms from his
suit we've all seen a whole bunch of
Iron Man's model prime armor it works a
little bit like Black Panthers costume
like it actually just come out of a
couple different pieces but the biggest
difference between model prime in the
previous versions of his armors is that
it can become any version of the armor
that it needs to so we could just be a
normal version of the suit like we see
him walking around in it has extra
pieces that stick out of the back that
helps with stabilizing when he's in low
orbit or in outer space
it could also reconfigure itself into a
Hulk Buster if it needed to we of course
have seen all the pictures of the new
traditional Hulkbuster armor they're
just calling it Hulk buster 2.0 then
there's the Pepper Potts rescue armor
there's actually a funny scene where
Gwyneth Paltrow is doing an interview
talking about wearing dots on herself
where she kind of confirms that she's
going to be wearing a version of the
armor is when is the next Iron Man and
why will I see Pepper Potts back in the
Marvel are you are you in the Avengers
the next Avengers I am I allowed to say
I say you are okay yeah I am yeah do you
still have powers
you still have powers can you still do
the flame thing with your hand um you
know to be totally honest I'm unclear
because it's so secretive and it's all
on green-screen and I'm not exactly sure
and they don't let me say anything is
there any chance at any point when you
were working on the movie did you thrust
your hand towards someone wearing like a
blue suit with ping-pong balls glowed on
Pluto
yes then you still have powers but I
think it'll wind up being a unique
version that's tailored specifically for
her there are a couple characters that
obviously don't need weapons like the
Hulk
is a weapon Captain Marvel is a weapon
so it's not like they walk around with
giant guns because they are the gun but
Mark Ruffalo did post this funny picture
of Hulk walking with a bag over his
shoulder now in the caption he wrote
that this was his final scene that he
filmed for infinity war so it doesn't
mean that the Hulk is just going off
into the distance but the reason why
people thought that might be the case is
is because this is very bill bixby Hulk
TV show
during that show he sort of hitchhiked
his way across the United States trying
to hide from the authorities helping
people along the way having adventures
so it's just a very Incredible Hulk TV
show type of moment I've already done a
couple videos about Thor's axe yaar
Bjorn and whatever they call it during
the movie this is the space Forge where
he makes it but the pictures that Marvel
has posted are actually kind of
ambiguous
it actually looks almost like it could
be ultimate Thor's hammer because it has
the little piece on it but it seems like
it's gonna be closer to Yarber yorn from
the comics the reason why the handle
looks similar to Mjolnir ziz is because
this is the same place where Mjolnir was
forged that's why Thor's going back
there black panther pretty much the same
because there isn't a much time between
the end of Black Panther and the
beginning of infinity war obviously all
the city defenses all the cool tech that
they have in Wakanda you'll see that
during the Black Panther movie so you
have a pretty good idea of what they're
capable of when we get to infinity war
but I've already done a video explaining
the prelude comic where it talks about
how Sheree helps reboot winter soldiers
mind using some of their tech that's on
par with the stuff that they use to
create Ultron so they have really
advanced AI and Wakanda too but they
also confirm that in addition to the
new shield that she makes for Captain
America she also fashions a new arm for
Winter Soldier so the arm works pretty
much the same way only now it's that
much stronger but aside from Hawkeye's
Ronin gear black widow's blonde hair
Scarlet Witch and vision don't really
have new gear but they are more powerful
they're more connected to the Infinity
gem her powers are based on it so they
just grow organically vision is
literally connected to it so he's
learned more about it in the time that
we haven't seen him for the most part
the rest of the characters are the exact
same as the last time you saw him no
huge upgrades with the exception of
teenage Groot call that an upgrade but
he's like 13 14 years old so you can see
he's about this tall compared to the
other characters but it's a reminder
about the trailers coming this weekend
Disney only bought two spots and that's
for all of its different rail so it has
Marvel Pixar traditional Disney stuff
black panther is the most likely
candidate it's totally possible that
there's an infinity war promo but
remember that Disney has a bunch of
other films like wrinkle and time it
also has Pixar's Incredibles too so
don't be surprised if they don't drop
infinity war and they just do it later
during the week which is kind of what's
happening with Deadpool - in the venom
trailer because instead of dropping
Super Bowl trailers they're just opting
to attach their next promos to Black
Panthers release which is in about two
weeks so anything that you don't see
this weekend will drop in the next two
weeks so no worries about that once
Black Panther hits theaters then they'll
start spamming infinity war footage but
there will be a new round of the
Infinity Gauntlet giveaway all you have
to do to enter just be a subscriber and
share the video using the tools on the
watch page click here for my
non-spoilery Black Panther movie
reaction and click here to rewatch that
ant-man
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight